all right let's go with E for lets roll
here I feel if I feel very laid back
with this stream right now I feel a very
relaxed plane let's see hmm let's see
let's see let's see what about d4 hmm I
want to do something different let's do
this okay scotch gambit I guess don't
immediately recapture it's Bishop c4 now
watch out for tricky stuff
what is that tricky stuff here
tricky stuff snip on half seven okay
follow up Queen D five and I think
there's no I think I'm confusing certain
things right now oh wait a second
somebody pointed this out to me I think
I'm trying to recall something that
somebody gave me a tip about not taking
the bishop right away and instead giving
a check on each five and then taking the
bishop yes yes yes yes yes
yepper I think it's worthwhile to do
that I can't recall who who gave me that
tip but now notice the big difference
here look at this diagonal how it's
opened up and this rook is more
vulnerable my opponent does not have a
dark square bishop taking this pawn bad
news happening soon
so the King King Castle I don't think
that black even gets to hang on to a pun
and they really just take here and allow
such development that has got to be bad
stuff happening fast so now the Queen's
hitting the rub pin City happening maybe
very soon this is likely a move just to
exchange Queens but I definitely don't
want to exchange Queens so where can my
Queen go where she's just going to be
able to be happy for a moment here
we're spending a lot of time here in not
just this game every game I just I just
want it to be easier can it be easier
alright I'm gonna go here
wait exchanges I want to get here
eventually with the temp off the bishop
plays here it's gonna be a little bit
annoying I think or maybe no not so much
I was thinking that in response to
Bishop g4 I have to do this right away
but I believe I could first insert
Bishop g5 hit the Queen and only been do
this additionally if the knight place to
be for this is one of the things I had
already calculated when I decided on the
c2 square for my queen and it's that if
the knight makes use of before I have a
form so I think I do run with this right
now however is there gonna be an issue
with bishop here night here no no no no
no no for the same reason as night b4 is
not good night d4 is not good so maybe I
could be more general with my if I were
to if I'm to like come up with like a
general principle in just this very
specific instance right here that wasn't
that best right there but really it's
it's not the knight specifically coming
to b4 or d4 it's about the night playing
to the fourth rank so I'm kind of doing
a little bit small grouping right there
to help better understand this position
right now so he can't make use of either
one of these squares because of this
Queen check idea and he's pretty much
having to go back or whatever anyhow
it's not good so where does the Queen go
Knight d2 coming up for me I have a look
well pretty decent lead in development
that
now castling in this direction is going
to be very difficult alright let's just
get more development in that this darks
for a bishop I'm I'm really trying to
what am I really trying to do trying to
make it inconvenient for black to Castle
queenside I'm assuming questions will be
thrown to the Bishop h6 and eventually
shutting it down with the g5 I wonder if
I should just voluntarily go to e3 maybe
this is a better spot not wait to first
be having this g5 advance I like just
coming here right away
pointing at H or a seven if Castle
queenside well I already have two half
open files the C and D right here so
there's a I'm pretty sure a ready-made
type of an attack maybe even with this
b4 and now with this rook lift woo
should I be concerned about eventual
sacrifices on this square it seems like
rook here is not a long ways off or
maybe I could throw question this bishop
first yeah let me do that what are you
gonna do bishop oh man I was actually
just speaking in the chap I kept talking
about queenside castle haha maybe that's
a form of cheating right there I was
looking at the twitch chat I shouldn't
do that I did catch it out of the corner
of my eye there I think a bunch of
people were saying you can't castle
that's right this King guy I took on f7
earlier you dummy you dummy move six
what do you think you did I move six
okay so there is no Queen sigh Castle
okay then I I could Castle though I can
cancel and I'm going to castle I did
castle all right so what's what is the
plan I have to start saying that by the
way whenever I upload a video I try to
watch a little bit of it to make sure
everything is okay from when I go from
twitch to YouTube and one of the things
that I say way too much and I'm sure
others can add other things but what's
the scoop I just just kept coming off it
seemed like every other line that's all
I said what's the scoop was a scoop come
on you can eat some better material here
what's the plan it's a great adjustment
all right let's go with the night two
reasons well really one of the main
reason here f4f for my f-pawn wants to
rumble monster rumble E E and F pond
let's go let's go the night could play
here so wat though dark square bishop
back him up he's boxing out the night b4
b5 robbed this night of what let's chase
the Sun night around he can't be too
comfortable and we are both under a
minute usually I recognize when I'm
under a minute sooner but just realizing
it now where's he going
get over here King don't you go so fast
this Bishop has to be a giant pain
doesn't he
you guys should have kicked the Knight
first before playing here I was silly of
me
cuz now he can make use of this square
let's do that I don't want to trade
these rooks maybe I should have let's do
this I want to be able to take here with
what let's do that
I'm not going quick here eighteen they
got a time edge I should just take the
pawn that's why I went there
okay all right there goes that pun
opposite color Bishop ending oh he's a
pain
giant pain right here it's a giant pain
it's close to me isn't it my way run
away fast my queen wants to sneak in
clock situation watch out for the mates
tricky mates hit a bishop push up on
capture a pine and give a check have a
bishop back main mode anything mode no
tiny mode check the server mode yes all
right it's saying that I have time okay
there we go
good game rat race as usual these are
five minutes all right let's hit that
rewind button and let's see well you
can't take that pun I think you'll want
to look into Knight f6 here if I'm not
mistaken knight Knight f6 is a move to
consider I think right now and
definitely right now I believe Knight
right here is considered a mainline
there are the main line right there
Knight f6 if pawn push then there is the
d5 advance so Bishop here and then 994
it's a little bit lengthy you end up
with a structure where you have doubled
see pawns but I'm having to invest or
I'm having to give up my bishop pair in
order to double those see pawns but look
into that this is this is not a you
can't go into this one and again if your
person is watching that gave me this
little tip about first inserting this
check and then doing that thank you
because it's a better improvement to
induce this advance or being a spot to
at least chase the king to a dark Square
and take this bishop width check so
because I've done this before where I've
given the check and just immediately
taken the bishop but I like the
insertion of Queen age five there so
yeah you can't you can't get involved
with this particular line this is step
in the wrong direction right so look
into Knight f6 here or I like I think
the main line is a good one to be going
forward with Knight f6 pawn push d5 look
into that okay